much for coming isn't it been a good day
decent way to spend your Saturday rather
than pushing a trolley around IKEA
buying coat hangers and tea lights and
all of those things this is good I'm
standing between you and the craft beer
event which is somebody that doesn't
drink my talk will probably be about
four and a half hours so get one in
right now I've got a confession to make
I a few years ago my interest in
designing for the web completely waned I
just lost interest in what I was seeing
and I really felt like Web Design had
stagnated that we somehow had replaced
creativity with trying to make things
predictable and that somehow ideas were
less important than data or research or
all of these are they're terribly boring
things
oh I need to I think I need to change
the title sorry alright now this is
we all know this isn't going to end well
just like when Geri Halliwell left the
Spice Girls now when I began to work on
some projects with a legendary newspaper
and magazine designer guy called Mark
Porter I became fascinated by art
direction and magazine and editorial
design there's someone that hadn't
studied those things when I went to art
school
everything about this area was different
it was exciting it was new and the more
inspired I got by magazine design the
faster that my enthusiasm for designing
for the web bounced back and you know I
often wonder why so many web designers
think that print is somehow
old-fashioned or irrelevant to what we
do losing my microphone technology so I
now buy magazines as regularly as I
possibly can and a week before last
Christmas I actually spent some time I
get very confused with these two remotes
I was in a magazine store with some
friends it's sort of evangelizing about
magazine and print design and friend of
mine suggested you know why don't you
actually write a series about magazine
and editorial design and and what you
find fascinating and how we can actually
learn some lessons from those things and
apply them to the web and that actually
that conversation sparked the idea for a
series on inspired design decisions
which I'm doing for Smashing Magazine
and every month I choose an art director
or a designer or publication or a
magazine look at the what makes that
design distinctive the lessons
we can learn from it and then how we can
use those lessons to make better work
for the web so I'm really happy to say
that you know I'm inspired and I'm
motivated again and I really hope that
this series is going to do the same
thing for for other people and when book
cases are now absolutely chock-full of
magazine design inspiration you know the
collection is still growing and this is
a magazine that I picked up fairly
recently it's a magazine on printmaking
called pressing matters and when I read
it I was immediately transported back to
art school
my wife will remember when my fingers
were chopped up from using lino cutting
tools I just smelt like turpentine all
the time which I'm sure was very
attractive and pressing matters has this
really simple but distinctive style and
it uses a very limited color palette it
often connects the color of elements to
other elements which are found in nearby
objects like illustrations or
photographs and the end result is very
much like the thing that we want to
accomplish on the web which is a
connected experience and it uses layout
patterns which produce this rhythm that
flows throughout the magazine and it
uses differently sized layout modules
which speed you past smaller pieces of
information pages that are packed with
prints and then the pace will slow you
right down using larger panels so that
you linger on the reproductions of the
artwork and what struck me about
pressing matters in particular is how
this magazine contained a variety of
different layer
Styles which were demanded by the
different types of content but it still
maintains a really high degree of
consistency right the way throughout and
whereas so many people I hear recite
this mantra that the web isn't print
there's so much that we can learn which
will make our web designs better so when
I looked more closely that how these
pages were constructed what I discovered
was a layered compound grid which was
comprised of two and three column grids
overlaid on each other
which ran throughout the magazine and a
compound grid is a tall which was made
famous by a typographer and graphic
designer called Carl Gerstner anybody
heard of Gerstner so she's nodding
quietly Gerson there was a Swiss artist
perhaps he was one of the most
influential typographers trouble is
books about his worker being out of
print for decades so it's pretty
unlikely that you're gonna have seen his
work firsthand but it's still been
incredibly influential and by a really
strange coincidence I actually found out
recently that girlis ad agency created
ads for sina which is a swiss large
format camera maker that i actually
worked for back in the 1990's and
Gerstner was one of the first designers
to exploit the creative flexibility of
using grids and it's the compound grid
which he created for this which is
Capitol magazine which became one of his
best-known creations and given the
potential variety of capitols content
Gerstner needed a grid which would help
him to lay out any type of content
consistently and without any
restrictions
so Gessner created what he called a
mobile grid not the kind of mobile that
you and I know about and this grid is
most likely what you'll find if you do a
Google search for compound grid if
you're confused so was I so this
compound grid designed by design for
capital of God's going to rule it looks
incredibly complex so I'm gonna break it
down into you were into its constituent
parts there are 58 rows and columns in a
mobile grid Gerstner started with just
one so content in this single module
fills the full width of the page then he
divided up single module into two
columns and rows and using two columns
in this way results in a reassuring
symmetrical design and that large module
can also be divided into three columns
and rows and he's keeping the gutter and
the margins the same regardless of how
many grid modules he uses and by
splitting that module into four those
columns of content feel a lot more
formal the over and overall impression
is that this design is a serious one and
when this full-page module is divided
into five columns and separated by two
different spatial zones this design
feels a lot more technical and with
gerson as mobile grid you can use each
set of columns and rows separately or
you can turn them into a compound either
by overlaying or by stacking one on top
of the other so dividing the page up
into six columns six rows enables this
incredible variety of
layout options and the flexibility of a
compound grid comes from the interplay
of two or more grids so a compound grid
is two or more grids of any type that
can be column grids modular symmetrical
or asymmetrical grids all on one page
and they can occupy these separate areas
or they can overlap and just as a simple
thing you've got to start playing with
with compound grids you can start making
a simple compound by overlaying two
columns one where the two grids one with
two columns and one with three columns
and by using any number of equally sized
columns and rows this layout forms this
consistent pattern it's an even rhythm
we talked about or heard about bootstrap
a few times today nobody's talked about
what I think is possibly the worst
aspect of the the bootstrap phenomenon
which is everybody using a twelve column
symmetrical grid as the starting point
for every design if you think of each
one of those columns as a beat and you
tap those out on your chair what you
don't get is a particularly entertaining
rhythm if you compare that to the rhythm
that you'd get from a 2:1 one to type
pattern you can understand why using a
compound grid can change both the visual
results but also your mental model as to
how you use grids so a compound grid of
two or three columns creates a rhythmic
pattern of two one one two and then for
an altogether different design you know
perhaps one which is using its Halla
size type to suggest the movement in
this car
you know you might stagger the
paragraphs to create this dynamic
diagonal which runs
through the page and changing that
compound formation to combine three and
four columns creates a completely
different rhythmic pattern this one is 3
1 2 2 1 3 this same combination can make
for a very different impression by
combining column widths from both grids
to inform for example the width of my
running text and that column perfectly
matches the width of that portrait
orientation cart over on the right hand
side and this time I set the block of
running text across 2 of those columns
and I've derived the width of those by
combining column widths from both the 4
and the 5 column grid and overlaying 4
overlaying 4 columns with 5 leads this
really unusual with mcpadden 6 1 4 3 4 1
6 come to how we can implement those in
a minute
so in this version of the design this
large image shows off the iconic shape
of this e type car and then the solid
block of text sits right underneath the
wheels and we get the width of that
column from both the 4 column and the 6
column grid and then this design
literally places that e type at the
center of the action and it wraps the
text around both sides which adds real
energy and movement to the design so I
mostly use fraction units fr units as
the pattern for my compound grids and
the result of a 2 + 3 compound is 4
columns where the outer two columns are
double the width of the two inner
columns whereas a combination of 3 and 4
column grids is going to result in
six columns and this rhythmic pattern of
three one two two one three and a
combination of four and five columns is
going to result in six columns in a
different rhythmic pattern and then
finally combining four and six columns
together creates eight columns and two
of them are much much narrower than the
rest and that's a rhythmic pattern there
of of 2 1 1 2 2 1 1 2 which is actually
a pattern I use a lot so a compound grid
might seem complex but it's actually no
more difficult to implement than any
other 8 or 12 column grid you know I
need ridiculously few HTML elements to
actually implement this layout and the
CSS is even more compact it's much more
stable even than using other layout
tools so I'll tell you about an art
director from the 1940s and 50s a guy
called Alexi broad herbage and I began
to study brought of itch when I became
fascinated by editorial and magazine
design and I was drawn to just how
precise brought of it his work was in
particular the way in which he brought
photographs and texts together I also
kind of appreciate his rebellious
rejection of anything that he considered
to be mediocre he was actually born in
what is today Belarus and he moved to
Paris where he actually beat Pablo
Picasso to second place in a poster
competition amazingly and then moved to
the United States where he taught and
told his students to astonish me which I
just love that kind of attitude and
Harper's Bazaar became branagh [ __ ]
most well-known project and to keep his
designs fresh he often commissioned work
from European artists people like Jean
Cocteau and Marc Chagall and Man Ray not
the kind of people you'd expect in a
commercial fashion magazine and his
knowledge of photography gave his work
this classic feel and he often cropped
photographs in really unexpected ways he
placed them off censored sometimes bleed
them outside the margins of the page to
create these compositions which were
full of energy and movement and
throughout his career at Harper's Bazaar
and then beyond he frequently used
content in photographs or illustrations
to inform the placement and the position
and the shape of his text and his color
choices were also bold he used large
blocks of color for emphasis and I just
find his design processes fascinating as
the finished work because I often learn
more about how someone thinks by looking
at their work in progress than I do at
what they ended up with and brought
ovitch Dizz began designing his layouts
using sketches on paper and then he
arranged those spreads on the floor of
his studio to create this the pace of
the magazine now this might seem at
first like a a random collection range
Minh of pictures but in fact everyone
was deliberately placed and it fills
this design with movement and we can use
the same technique today even when we're
designing flexible responsive layouts so
for this first
broader Vichy inspired design I'm just
gonna scatter four differently sized
images across the viewport and I can
arrange these images horizontally
vertically even diagonally depending on
the screen dimensions so to help me
design a consistent experience across
different screen sizes I often form my
own storyboard from a small series of
sketches so for smaller screens I'm
going to turn those images into a
horizontally scrolling panel and then on
medium sized screens I'm going to
scatter those images vertically to
maintain the visual hierarchy in that
portrait orientation now to develop this
design I can use a combination of CSS
grid and flecked Fox and CSS transforms
and my markup is incredibly minimal and
semantic I've only got three structural
elements for layout and then to
implement this design I'm going to use
that four plus six compound grid that I
showed you earlier and then I can place
each one of those elements onto the grid
and then reposition them using a media
query at the widest screen size and then
I can nudge or rotate those pictures to
give them that scattered look which
brought a [ __ ] inspired now people have
told me that designs like this are
appropriate for editorial design and
they might be you know relevant to print
but not for products or websites that
isn't the case at all this is an example
I used that same kind of scattered
pictured approach to bring this design
for a new electric Vespa scooter to life
so I don't accept that this stuff is
okay
but not for whether a broader which made
the double-page spread his playground
and using this large canvas to carefully
construct these compositions so facing
pages here allowed broader which the
possibility to contrast or to connect
both sides of the spread so this larger
screen design splits that viewport into
two columns and it uses color and shape
to reflect one side with the other and
all I need is three structural elements
to implement this design now I need a
heading a main element and an aside
element before it heard about the
importance of using these HTML elements
before and then on smaller screens all I
need are just foundation styles because
the normal flow is going to take care of
the order of the content but then for
medium medium sized screens I can apply
grid properties to both of those main
and a side elements so that I can then
position the content on the grid and
then for larger screens I can place
those main and their side elements onto
the grid using a couple of named lines
so with a little imagination with a
little inspiration we can make much more
distinctive and engaging designs now
shapes add movement to a design they
help draw people in they help connect an
audience with a story or with a product
and they make this tighter connection
between the visual and the written
content so inspired by brother Mitch for
this next design the shape of this
running text reflects the shape in the
header image which is opposite and I've
seen very very few examples of using CSS
shapes which go beyond just using basic
shapes and I wonder sometimes whether
that's because people
become so conscious of making designs
that are you know responsive and maybe
not understanding that you know your
browsers not only designed to not only
have to don't have to look the same
across different browsers but they don't
necessarily have to look the same across
different screen sizes either we ought
to be adapting our design while
maintaining a consistent look and feel
so you can also use shapes to to sculpt
structural shapes from solid blocks of
running text in the style of broader
pitch
so the mark-up that I need to implement
this design is similar to the previous
example it's just a header which
contains a picture element and then a
main element for the running text you
know of course designs like this aren't
going to make sense at every screen
width but you know who said that
websites need to look the same on every
screen now if you're using a browser
that's you know ancient that potentially
doesn't support CSS shapes no problem if
we think about things from a progressive
enhancement point of view then all we're
going to get is a standard straight
vertical column of text nobody dies
and it's often you need really little
markup to develop dynamic and original
layouts you know inside my main element
I've just got two SVG images which I use
to carve the shape of that running text
and then for larger screens I can just
apply a symmetrical two column grid to
the body place the header and the main
elements using these named lines and
then I can rotate that header image
clockwise and place the transform origin
in the center so that it stays in the
middle of my header and there all that
remains is we to float those SVG shape
images left and right so that the
running text runs between them and it
mirrors the shape of that rotated image
which was opposite so you can see a
ghost of those SVG images and that's the
end result now tools like CSS shapes
give us countless opportunities to
capture reader's attention keep people
engaged and flexible designs which
include precisely positioned elements
they were really hard to do using CSS
positioning and floats but modern said
CSS techniques have made these designs
much more straightforward to accomplish
and I hope that that's going to result
in a new generation of much more
inspired designs so this next design is
is again inspired by a spread from Alexi
brada which is from portfolio magazine
and here who use a striking combination
of black and white columns in a and a
bold splash of color
now before implementing any design again
I'm going to make a simple storyboard
just to demonstrate how these elements
are going to flow across a selection of
screen sizes and the footer which either
occupies the bottom on a small screen or
the hole of the right hand side on a
large screen it needs a little bit more
styling so to accomplish the stripey
background effect I'm actually just
going to use a CSS gradient rather than
using any images and then I can place a
position each one of those images and
use the clip path property to clip each
one so that only a third of them is
visible and this is a really useful
property I'm surprised that we don't see
this use more often online these
clipping paths can form any shape they
can form basic circles or ellipses or
complex polygon shapes with any number
of coordinates so for this first image
I'm going to clip the right-hand side
which is only going to leave the 33
percent on the black area I'm going to
position the second image absolutely I'm
going to use a lower Z index value which
is going to send it to the bottom of my
stacking order and then for the third
and final image I'm going to clip the
left-hand side which is going to leave
only that right portion visible and then
the design also includes an SVG circle
which I position over those images and I
can use a blend mode a mix blend mode
which tints the color of the elements
below it in the stacking order and again
you can see how that thing can adapt
across a selection of different screen
sizes using grid as appropriate
so since I discovered his work I think
broader [ __ ] has probably been the most
substantial influence on my design over
the past couple of years and his
inability to accept anything which is
mediocre it's pushed me still to try to
think beyond what's expected from a
product or from a website designer so
what tell you about beer fight law now
filer was actually born in Rio de
Janeiro in 1938 she worked on album
covers and book designs and magazines
and posters in Brazil and then moved to
Manhattan and in 1961 she was still only
25 years old she became an art assistant
and then one of the youngest and the
first female Co art directors at
Harper's Bazaar magazine and despite her
portfolio which contains things like
Richard Avedon famous pink space helmet
and John Lennon naked on the cover of
Rolling Stone she's actually been
described as the pioneering female art
director that you've never heard of you
know on top of everything she actually
once kissed Andy Warhol as well I
suppose today's equivalent would be me
kissing Hayden Pickering
what will come up here son so one of my
famous on the favorite quotes from beer
fight ler which could just as easily
apply will be describing the web is a
magazine should flow it should have a
rythm you can't look at one page alone
you have to visualize what comes before
and after good editorial design is all
about creating a harmonic flow I truly
believe that that is as appropriate to
the web as it was then and like Alexei
Ivanovitch she fundamentally understood
the dynamics of the double page spread
and her bold designs are only a part of
what makes her life and her work
fascinating even more important was how
her work reflected changes in society in
America during the 1960s and the bold
choices that she made to influence it
in fact she cast the first black model
on the cover of a mainstream fashion
magazine in 1965 and came under
incredible criticism for it I think it
was like over a decade later and to
another black model was on the cover of
Harper's Bazaar though she's done so
much to teach people who design for the
web today as much I think as she did to
the magazine designers who followed her
just hope in some small way with talks
like this that I can help people fall in
love with her work the way that I did so
this is one design that really stands
out for me from Harper's Bazaar I just
love the way in which we have this kind
of contrast and yet balance between both
sides of the screen I wanted to play
with that I wanted to see how we might
adapt that
for the web but still keep it relevant
for products and websites so I want to
try to find ways through all of these
examples to illustrate that this is not
just an academic design exercise this is
something that we can and should
experiment with and apply to the work we
do online so to implement the this first
design I'm just using a minimal set of
structural elements as small as I can so
we've got a header a main and an aside
element which has the content now this
is where it starts to get interesting
because that landscape image fits really
well
on a larger size screen but when you use
it on a small screen if you look at that
on a phone we completely lose the visual
hierarchy of that particular page so we
need to change our image use a wider
format for screens which are wider than
they are tall so this media query which
can be used in style sheets as an
alternative to a more conventional with
query or it can be used on things like
picture elements so in landscape
orientation I've got a symmetrical two
column grid and this linear gradient
which fills the full height of the
screen and the result is this design
which adapts the layout depending on
whether the browser or the screen or the
device is in landscape or import rate
orientation now the Volkswagen Beetle
that were there no one's ever owned one
little car big personality so for this
next example which was inspired by beer
fighter
I wanted my design to have some
personality to match
so this large screen design uses this
enormous picture of the Beatles wheel to
emphasize contrast with the smallness of
that little car and three structural
elements make up the mark-up that I need
to implement this design again it's a
header for the large wheel picture a
figure which contains the the smaller
image of the car and then a main element
for my running text so before I get to
the large screen I just want to make
sure that I am maintain the contrast in
scale even on the smallest screens you
might notice there's a problem with some
of that you know one problem that I've
encountered a lot when developing
flexible layouts is this kind of
unintentional resizing of images so with
a fixed height on the header element and
100% width on the image this giant wheel
is going to get distorted I'm gonna give
that many an unintentional flat b/w an
unintentional flat tire fortunately
there's a way in which I can preserve
the aspect ratio using the object fit
property in CSS so contain preserves an
image aspect ratio while fitting inside
the parent containing box so the image
is contained inside the box
whereas cover preserves the aspect ratio
but this time it fills the whole box so
when this happens parts of the image
outside of that content box are going to
be hidden it's going to cover the
content box and then in this alternative
version of the design I can preserve the
difference in scale between those two
pictures at a variety of different
screen sizes and it's incredibly
important to consider how we can
maintain both a consistent expense
and maintain visual hierarchy across
different views of our same design now
fighters choice of bold colors was one
of the hallmarks of her work it
attracted me immediately so for this
next inspired design I contrast this
deep red with a vibrant yellow and then
I reverse the colors on both sides of
the design so while this fighter
inspired design it's really big on color
it's also incredibly small or mark up I
just need two structural elements I just
need a header which contains a figure
and a division and a main element which
also contains a figure and a division
and then for medium side screens I want
the figure and the divisions inside both
of those elements to occupy half the
height of the viewport so I'm gonna add
a symmetrical two column grid and a
minimum height thereof a hundred VH
viewport height units and then I can
place those on to my symmetrical grid
now I want this design to fill the
screen with color from edge to edge so
on larger screens I'm going to apply
that asymmetrical two column grid which
is going to extend the full height of my
body element and then I can reposition
those in those elements for larger
screens so fight ler has just done so
much to teach people who design for the
web today even without knowing it sadly
she died of cancer at the age of only 42
and there is only one book retrospective
book available about fighters work it
was written by her Nick
whew and it was only published in
Portuguese in Brazil in 2012 and it took
me absolutely months to track down a
copy eventually I got one it was the
most expensive book that I've ever
bought my financial director is sitting
at the back there but do you know what
for the inspiration that I got and for
the motivation and for just a rekindling
of my interest in design it was worth
every penny so if I want you to take
away any kind of message from this talk
today is that there's so much more that
we can do with web design so many bold
choices that we can make we don't have
to conform to somebody else's idea of
what constitutes good design for a
digital product or for a website we can
use instincts we can use our gut to
drive an idea forward we don't have to
research it or put it through a focus
group or you know test it to death we
can just make bold design choices and
produce work which you know is
incredible whoops
so speaking of work which is slightly
less incredible I did write a book and
it would be rude of me not to promote it
here you can get that have a look at
this art direction for the web com there
is also a video series which is
available because we're all friends here
you can get 50% discount with the code
ace of spades and thank you very much
for encouraging my bad behavior
[Applause]
[Applause]